are these the names of the characters
he's played Samir Hussein no that's who
took the picture oh
for you guys for crediting the
photographers hey I'm Mike Abby and I
play Donatello what's up guys I'm Brady
Newton I play Raphael hi I'm Shimon
Brown Jr and I play Michelangelo and I'm
Nicholas Cantu and I play Leonardo and
yo what's up this is Ice Cube and I
played the one and only Superfly I'm IO
debris and I play April O'Neil I'm Seth
Rogen and I play Bebop and we are the
cast of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Mutant Mayhem and we're gonna do a
little quiz to see which Turtle we are
yeah let's see if casting got it right
do it let's see check it out yeah
yeah
first what word describes you best
confident wise funny smart adventurous
or rebellious I'm like all six
to me confident yeah that that speaks to
confidence it's very wise you know I'm
funny as hell you are
um smart is all get out and you know
I'll give a damn about nothing so I'm
rebellious man yeah I'm gonna stick with
wives
love that I like that too I like a
little bit of everything
people say they're adventurous but like
nobody's climbing mountains
I'm gonna go confident confident I'm
choosing why I like it like it's
interesting money probably best describe
I wish I was these other things more but
I think I have to realistically go with
money
I'm gonna say smart
yeah thank you all right next question
is pick a color for your superhero
costume red blue beige black purple or
orange what do you want black
[Music]
yes I'm also picking black okay what's
up hey you know I didn't know we keep
you know I thought we you know okay I
could we could do look I'm wise
your wife she's smart yeah every time
she's following my leaves so black yeah
I guess I'll go with beige then
[Laughter]
you motivated into this corner
[Music]
I'm Going Black
I'm The Dark Knight
if you could hang out with a group of
Hollywood siblings for a day who would
it be we got Liam Chris and Luke we got
a Luke Hemsworth Beyonce and Solange
Luke Hemsworth by the way conservatively
one foot shorter than his brother I
actually yeah wow Jody hillabini
feldstein Jayden and Willow Smith Billy
eilish and Phineas O'Connell or the
Kardashians I'm picking the Carnage
I don't know
[Music]
I don't know Jonah Hill looks impressed
I'm hanging out with Johnny here Joan
and beanie they're people I actually do
hang out with so I'm very happy I'm
going with Beyonce and Salon
I literally have to they're probably
more
experience yeah and I hope that they'd
take care of me adopt me whatever you
can join choose another comic book
character you'd want to have as your
Sidekick Superman Spider-Man Deadpool
Catwoman the Hulk or Joker Joker Joker
it's honestly Deadpool and Spiderman you
know how much chaos he would cause in
your life
Deadpool Deadpool's deadly and he's also
like super fun Joker is soloing Deadpool
I'm sorry but like
I gotta go with Spider-Man I'm gonna do
the Hulk because he's green and funny
and we're green turtles so I think it
makes sense I'd want to hang out with
the Hulk as your Sidekick as my sidekick
respect the muscle you got he's got
muscles
that's what you like you know I mean
it's like you're gonna do what we want
to do because my man if you get angry
you don't want to see him we're gonna
move furniture okay my man get angry all
this furniture is about to be realized
respect respect so you're walking in you
know with the man he was also a doctor
and he's undercover he's a doctor so you
actually gotta
he could he could prescribe you anything
oh I'm going with the Hulk too then
because of that yeah not for his
strength for his powers of prescription
well bro
we'll have this conversation after this
interview I'm gonna do Catwoman because
I like free stuff yeah she steals she
steals yeah sorry
what happens now it's time to face off
against the villain what song do you
choose to play Bad Blood by Taylor Swift
Holding Out for a Hero by Bonnie Tyler
Scarface push it to the Limit by Paul
Ingman You Can't Touch This by MC Hammer
Uptown funk by Mark Ronson and Bruno
Mars we're Straight Out of Compton by
NWA hmm
yeah
I'm playing straight out I'm sorry I'm
also playing Straight Outta Compton
Vibes wise and yay wise exactly he got
it I'm also going Straight Out of
Compton if push Rhymes Like weight was
an option
very good I don't know how many of these
are great
guys
so much yeah I'm fighting and they're
like you're just gonna be dodging every
attack
I kind of like that one yeah finally
pick an actor to star in an action film
we got Chris Evans are these the names
of the characters he's played Samir
Hussein
what does that say no that's who took
the picture
he got it good for you guys for
crediting the photographers Chris Evans
Uma Thurman Keanu Reeves gently hit you
Carlos Esposito or Jennifer Lopez
Keanu I'm going Keanu okay I'm going
with Jennifer Lopez because I did an
action movie with her that's right
Anaconda you know that's right man and
it has the greatest line in movie
history the snakes out here just speak
[Applause]
[Music]
you're known for being different and
standing out for the rest interesting
but you teach people that it's okay to
March to the beat of your own drums and
do things in your own special way love
that for you know that for you you got
Michelangelo your witty creative and
very social like Michelangelo you also
like to have a good time and you have a
unique ability to lighten the mood in
any situation sometimes people might
misinterpret your playfulness as a lack
of care or interest but deep down you
take things very seriously and you're
always there when it's on shop and so
that's all of us we all got that so I
think I got my perfect I like wraps I
thought I was gonna end up being
Superfly to be honestly yourself okay
wow there's a little flaw on BuzzFeed
yeah
it was weird we just took the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles turtle quiz and
none of us got our right Turtles I don't
think right
Turtles squish yeah oh yeah you guys
could do this at home right so find out
which Ninja Turtle you are and make sure
to check out Teenage Ninja Turtles me
and Mayhem in theaters only August 2nd
August second
thank you